It's Michelle from Lab Muffin Beauty
Science: chemistry PhD, skincare nerd, and
professional sunscreen guinea pig. Today
I'm going to be talking about whether
you need to wear sunscreen indoors. Since
most of us are staying indoors, I've had
a lot of people ask me whether or not
they need to still wear sunscreen and I
personally haven't been wearing
sunscreen a lot indoors even though I am
a sunscreen nerd who owns all of the
sunscreens.
So do you need to wear sunscreen indoors? The answer is...
it depends.
*BOOOOOOOOOO*
I know, I know,
no-one likes hearing that, we all just
want to know if it's a "yes" or a "no" but
that's just not how reality works and we
all already know this. If I'm in the dark
in a windowless basement, of course it's
a no. If I'm under a netting dome in the
middle of summer in Australia, of course
it's a yes. So today I'm going to break
down the reasons why you may or may not
need a sunscreen indoors from a
scientific perspective so you can work
out what's best for your situation.
If you like to sort a video give it a
thumbs up, subscribe to my channel, and
click the notification bell so you don't
miss any videos. First let's quickly run
First, let's quickly run through the basics of what the point of sunscreen is. Sunscreen's main job is to
cut down how much UV reaches your skin.
Sunscreens have an SPF rating which
mostly measures how much UVB protection
you're getting. These shorter wavelengths
generally cause you to burn and they're
the wavelengths most strongly associated
with skin cancer. They don't go as deep
into your skin but they still cause your
skin to age faster. There's also UVA,
which are longer wavelengths. These burn
less but they cause prolonged tanning.
They contribute to melanoma, skin aging,
and hyperpigmentation. The broad spectrum
or UVA ratings on sunscreens tell you
how much UVA protection you're getting.
One of the problems with this is most of
the studies done on UV have been done on
people with white skin- we'll come back
to this point later. Some people have
also asked about light from screens,
particularly blue light. Sunscreen will
not protect you against blue light, not
even mineral sunscreens. Your screens
also don't produce anywhere near enough
blue light to make a difference. If you
want to know more about blue light I've
done a couple of videos on that, I'll
link them below. So back to UV. UV is bad
so sunscreen is good, but there are two
big variables that change whether or not
wearing sunscreen is good for your
situation:
how much UV you're exposed to, and how
susceptible your skin is to UV damage.
First let's talk about how much UV
you're exposed to when you're inside.
There are two types of ways you can be
exposed to UV from the sun. Direct
exposure is when the sun is shining
directly on you. When you're in the sun
you have direct exposure, when you're in
the shade you have no direct exposure.
Diffuse exposure is when the sun isn't
shining directly on you. Basically the
sun's UV is bounced onto you by either
air molecules high up in the sky or
objects around you. This also happens
with visible light and that's why you
can see objects that are in the shade.
Shorter wavelengths get diffused more, so
there's more diffuse UV around then
there is diffuse visible light. Obviously
there's more of both types of UV when
you're outside compared to inside, that's
because when you're indoors there are
things in between you and the sun and
the sky. Firstly there are solid walls
that block out direct UV if you're in
the shade, but when you're in the shade
you can still get diffuse UV. So how can
we estimate how much diffuse UV we're
getting? This is actually quite tricky.
There are lots of different factors that
change the ratio of direct to diffuse UV;
things like height of the sun, wavelength,
altitude... I read a bunch of papers and I
got really lost in the calculations.
*Michelle hearing her own voice overlapping on itself*
*THE VOICES GET LOUDER*
*unsettling music*
I had a great time researching this
video. I'm going to use 60% diffuse,
40% direct as a rough estimate on the higher
end of the scale. To estimate how much
diffuse UV you're getting you can use
something called sky view. Basically if
you're standing in the middle of the
field you're exposed to the inside of a
dome of sky. That's 100 percent exposure
to diffuse UV. If there's stuff blocking
your view of the sky; trees, buildings,
walls... then you get less sky view and
less diffuse UV. Uhat's why the distance
from the window matters. My window is
about 1.6 by 1.2 metres. To work out my
sky view...
*EMOTIVE VIOLIN AND PIANO MUSIC*
Since it's around head height I'm going
to approximate it as a rectangle.
The further away you are from the window, the
more accurate this is. If you're sitting
in the window and there's no trees or
buildings, then you're getting about 50%
sky view, so roughly 50% of the diffuse
UV. If you're further back from the
window, then the portion of your dome
that sky is going to be smaller. You can
see that it decreases exponentially. For
example in my room I sit three metres
away from the window so I get no direct
UV and I would get about 3%
diffuse UV from the sky. But I also have
trees, houses, blinds blocking up parts of
the sky, so only about 11% of the sky in
the window is actually visible. The UV
reflected by these objects is usually
less than 10% so I'm ignoring it. That
gives me 0.33% sky view, which means I'm getting
one three hundredths of the diffuse UV
compared to being in the open and one
five hundredths of the total UV compared
to being in the open. Even if I was only
one meter away from the window, that's
less than two percent sky view. I'm
getting about one percent of the amount
of total UV compared to being in the
open. But there's usually another thing
between us and the sun and that is glass,
Normal window glass usually blocks all
of the UVB from getting through but only
about 1/4 to 1/3 of UVA so in my
particular situation I'm going to get
none of the UVB and only one five
hundredth of the UVA compared to sitting
outside in the open. but the amount of UV
that you get out in the open also changes.
UV levels depend on where you live, the
time of day, and the time of year.
You might have heard of the UV index: this
tells you how much erythemal or sunburn
causing UV you're getting in a
particular location at a particular time.
You can look this up for your city. In
Sydney for example, you get a maximum of
12 in the middle of summer, and a max of
2 in the middle of winter. You can use
this to get an estimate of your UVA
levels. There is a myth that UVA levels
don't change much throughout the day or
throughout the year. That is a myth, they
do, they just don't change quite as much
as UVB does. You can see on these graphs
that UVA, the red line, still peaks in the
middle of the day and in the middle of
summer. The UV index is the best way to
work out how much UV you have in your
area. So once you work out roughly how
much UV you're getting, you can work out
what's best for your situation. Not
everyone needs to wear sunscreen every
day. I know it's a common saying in
skincare circles, that you need to wear
sunscreen every day, but this is not true
for everyone. There are benefits to UV
exposure which I talked about in my SPF
myths video. Our body produces vitamin D
after UVB exposure and nitric oxide
after UVA exposure so in many countries
including the UK and Australia, which is
the skin cancer capital of the world,
health authorities actually don't
recommend that you wear sunscreen every
day even if you go outside. The
Australian guidelines based this on the
UV index. If the maximum UV on a
particular day is 3 or above they
recommend wearing sunscreen but if it's
below 3 they recommend not wearing
sunscreen and intentionally trying to
get some sun exposure. You don't get much
UVB through glass so the vitamin D
benefits aren't there,but it isn't a
blanket rule that you have to wear
sunscreen every day. There's also a
racial bias in sunscreen studies. Like in
pretty much every other area of health,
the vast majority of studies have been
done on white people, who are melanin
deprived. Melanin is skin pigment which
acts as a natural sunscreen: not really
enough to hang out on the beach without
sunscreen, but enough to protect you from
some incidental exposure so the benefits
of wearing sunscreen for preventing
cancer and skin-aging
is going to be lower for people with
darker skin. On the flipside UVA does
tend to cause more pigmentation in dark
skin. This is more of an aesthetic thing
than a serious health issue so whether
or not you still need UVA protection
indoors really depends on how much you
care about pigmentation. You might also
be using skin care that increases your
sensitivity to UV like alpha hydroxy
acids and if you're using expensive
antiaging skincare then it might be
worth protecting yourself to maximize
your results. You might also have a
special condition that means you have to
care a lot more about UV exposure like
if you have a photosensitive disease, or
a family history of skin cancer. So all
of these factors are going to influence
your choice.
There are also some downsides to
sunscreen, the obvious one is cost. You
also have to spend time and effort
applying the sunscreen, and in a lot of
people like me, wearing sunscreen can
cause clogged pores. And there are also
health concerns about wearing sunscreen.
These health concerns are usually really
small, if you're going outside the
benefits greatly outweigh the risks, but
if you're exposed to only a tiny amount
of UV then these health concerns
combined with all of the other drawbacks
of wearing sunscreen might tip the
scales towards you not wearing sunscreen.
There's actually a really well-known
example that illustrates the difference
between diffuse indoor and direct indoor
exposure. It's this truck driver who
drove for 28 years with the windows
closed. Sun struck this side directly but
the other side only got diffuse exposure
through the side windows which are
similar to window glass. There is a huge
difference between the two sides. I think
it goes to show that direct UVA exposure
indoors is probably worth worrying about
but diffuse indoor UVA really depends on
your situation.
I hope you enjoyed this deep dive into
sunscreen science, if you did, you can
like and subscribe. You can also follow
me on Instagram @labmuffinbeautyscience
and check out my blog: labmuffin.com
See you next time to nerd out more about
the science behind beauty products.
*disturbing porn music*